>> Sean: WE HAVE THE GREATEST
AUDIENCE IN AUTOMATIC OF TV.
GREAT JOB.
THANKS NOR BEING WITH US.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
MIKE PENCE WILL JOIN US FOR AN
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
HIS BOOK HAS BEEN GETTING A LOT
OF BUZZ.
FIRST, WE'RE NOW SIX FULL DAYS
REMOVED FROM THE ELECTION AND
MORE THAN A DOZEN KEY RACES ARE
STILL UP IN THE AIR.
SEVERAL STATES AND DISTRICTS ARE
STILL COUNTING VOTES AND
RECOUNTING VOTES.
THERE'S STILL NO OFFICIAL CALL
ON WHO WILL TAKE THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
BUT TONIGHT WE CAN TELL YOU TO
TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
MULTIPLE OUTLETS INCLUDING "NEW
YORK TIMES" AND NBC HARDLY
MEMBERS OF THE VAST RIGHT WING
CONSPIRACY, THEY ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING PREDICTING
REPUBLICANS WILL IN FACT WIN THE
MAJORITY OF SEATS IN THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
NOW EVEN JOE BIDEN, BY THE WAY,
THINKS THAT THE GOP WILL TAKE A
MAJORITY.
I DON'T KNOW IF I TRUST HIS MATH
SKILLS.
WE'LL HAVE THE LATEST RESULTS
FROM THE CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS
YET TO BE CALLED INCLUDING TEN
RACES THAT REPUBLICANS NOW LOOK
POISED TO WIN.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, GOP CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE IS A BIG DEAL.
I'M NOT GOING TO UNDERSTATE,
THIS IT GIVESES REPUBLICANS THE
POWER TO SET THE AGENDA,
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS.
IT GIVES THEM THE POWER TO
SUBPOENA AND INVESTIGATE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ON NUMEROUS
IMPORTANT ISSUES, SUBPOENA
WITNESSES, STOP THE LEFT'S
RADICAL AGENDA AND OF COURSE
THEY HAVE THE POWER OF THE
PURSE.
DESPITE THE LIES FROM THE MEDIA
MOB, WE NEVER PREDICTED THIS RED
WAVE.
IN FACT, WE WARNED ALL YEAR LONG
THAT THIS ELECTION WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY CLOSE BECAUSE WE WERE
ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT BELLWETHER
STATES.
WE TALKED ABOUT TOSS-UP STATES
WITH THE BALANCE OF POWER
DECIDED IN A FEW OF THESE PURPLE
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
I'M GETTING A LITTLE SICK AND
TIRED OF BEING LIED ABOUT.
WE'LL REFRESH THEIR MEMORY AND
REMIND YOU.
>> THREE KEY SWING STATES, IF
YOU GO BACK TO 2016 THAT PUT
TRUMP IN VICTORY.
THE COMBINED VOTE OF THOSE THREE
SWING STATES, 70,000 VOTES.
2020, 43,000 VOTES IN THREE
STATES.
THAT WOULD BE GEORGIA, WISCONSIN
AND ARIZONA DECIDED THE
ELECTION.
IF YOU STAY HOME, DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE LIKELY TO WIN.
YOU'LL GET THE GOVERNMENT YOU
DESERVE.
THE SENATE IS ALWAYS TOUGH.
WE HAVE EVERY BELLWETHER STATE
AS YOU KNOW.
NOT EVERY STATE IS AN EASY RUN
FOR THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT A GUARANTEED WAVE
ELECTION.
ANYONE THAT SAYS REPUBLICANS
HAVE A LOCK ON THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE, THEY'RE LYING TO YOU.
THEY DON'T KNOW.
THE RACES CAN BE EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE IN EVERY BELLWETHER
STATE.
SINCE DAY 1, WE CAUTIONED
AGAINST ALL OF THIS RED WAVE
EXUBERANCE.
ACCORDING TO THE POLLS, NEARLY
EVERY KEY RACE WAS WITHIN ONE OR
TWO POINTS.
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR.
SOME SWING STATES LIKE
WISCONSIN, THE REPUBLICANS
PULLED OUT A WIN.
DOUG MASTRIANO, I DON'T
INDEPENDENT BE HE'S PRO LIFE BUT
HE DID NOT SUPPORT EXCEPTIONS
FOR RAPE OR INSIST OR THE
MOTHER'S LIFE.
THAT POSITION WAS TOO RADICAL
FOR VOTERS IN THAT PURPLE STATE.
HE LOST BY 14.
SENATE CANDIDATE DR. OZ HELD A
MUCH MORE MODERATE POSITION.
HE LOST BY A LOWER LEVEL.
ODD SPLIT TICKET IN PENNSYLVANIA
WHICH IS ALMOST UNHEARD OF BY
DOUBLE DIGITS.
NOW, STILL IT WAS NOT ENOUGH.
MEANWHILE IN MICHIGAN,
REPUBLICANS LIKELY
UNDERPERFORMED BECAUSE OF THE
ABORTION REFERENDUM ON THE
BALLOT.
TUDOR DIXON RAN AN AMAZING
CAMPAIGN.
SHE HAD A GREAT DEBATE.
JUST WIPED THE FLORIDA WITH
GRETCHEN WHITMIRE.
BUT STILL LOST TO LOCK DOWN
LIBERAL GOVERNOR.
IN OTHER STATES WHERE DEMOCRATS
FARED WELL, THE FEAR MONGERING,
THE LIES WERE CLEARLY EFFECTIVE
MORE THAN I THOUGHT THEY WOULD
BE.
REPUBLICANS WERE NEVER GOING TO
BAN SOCIAL SECURITY.
THE DEMOCRATS KNEW STUDENT LOAN
DEBT BEING FORGIVEN WOULD NOT
MAKE IT.
BIDEN IS ALREADY BACKING AWAY
FROM THE CODIFIES OF ROE.
THE DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINT
ABOUT DEMOCRACY IN PERIL, THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE TO OUR
REPUBLIC IS OUR INABILITY TO
COUNT VOTES, ESPECIALLY IN
PLACES WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
CHARGE.
AGAIN, HERE WE ARE.
ANOTHER ELECTION YEAR.
UNABLE TO CALL MORE THAN A DOZEN
KEY RACES.
IT IS IDIOTIC.
ARE YOU HAPPY WITH WHAT YOU'RE
WITNESSING IN IN THE STATE OF
ARIZONA, NEVADA, ALASKA AND
CALIFORNIA?
THIS IS A NATIONAL
T
EMBARRASSMENT.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
OVER HALF THE COUNTRY ALLOWS
AUTOMATIC OF THIS EARLY VOTING
FIVE WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
INCLUDING 50 DAYS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
NO WONDER WHY THE TRUST FUND
BRAT WAITED TO THE LAST WEAK OF
OCTOBER AFTER HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VOTES WERE COST.
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA.
BALLOTS ARE MADE AUTOMATICALLY
WITHOUT APPLYING FOR ONE.
WHAT COULD GO WRONG?
IN ARIZONA, I HAVE NO IDEA WHY
IT TAKEN SO LONG TO CAST EVERY
VOTE.
IN ALASKA, WE'LL BE LUCKY TO
KNOW BEFORE THANKSGIVING.
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
IS THIS THE BEST WE CAN DO?
ARE YOU HAPPY?
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE A
DEMOCRAT OR A REPUBLICAN.
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
TRUST IS SHATTERED.
OF COURSE, THERE'S A CLEAR
PATHWAY TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS.
WE SEND PEOPLE TO THE MOON.
THEY LAND, THEY WALKED AROUND.
THEY GET BACK IN THEIR ROCKET
SHIP AND THEY HEAD HOME.
AND THEY LAND SAFELY.
WE CAN'T DO BETTER THAN WHAT'S
GOING ON AROUND THE COUNTRY?
WHY NOT MAKE ELECTION DAY A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY?
WHY NOT MAKE IT WHERE EVERY ONE
VOTES IN PERSON, PAPER BALLOTS?
NO EXCEPTIONS EXCEPT FOR THE
ELDERLY AND MILITARY, PEOPLE OUT
OF TOWN.
WE CAN MAKE THOSE EXCEPTIONS.
PARTISAN OBSERVERS WATCHING THE
VOTING AND WATCH THE COUNT.
CHAIN OF CUSTODY PROTOCOLS WILL
ENSURE INTEGRITY IN EVERY
ELECTION.
CONFIDENCE IN EVERY RESULT.
BACK TO THIS YEAR'S RESULTS.
WHILE WE DON'T HAVE THE FINAL
VOTE TOTALS IN SEVERAL KEY
STATES, THE BALANCE OF POWER IN
THE HOUSE SEEMS ALL BUT CERTAIN.
AS IT STANDS NOW, REPUBLICANS
NEED SIX MORE SEATS FOR A 218
PERSON MAJORITY.
LAST NIGHT THE EDITOR OF THE
LEFT-LEANING COOK POLITICAL
REPORT SAID BETWEEN ARIZONA ONE,
AIR 66, DEMOCRATS DREAMS OF
HOLDING THE HOUSE MAJORITY
PROBABLY DIED TONIGHT.
IN ARIZONA, ONE OF THE
REPUBLICAN INCUMBENTS HAS A
3,000 VOTE LEAD.
OF THE APPROXIMATELY 11,000
VOTES LEFT, THEY ARE LIKELY FROM
RED AREAS OF THE DISTRICT.
IN ARIZONA 6, THE REPUBLICAN
INCUMBENT HAS A 2,000 VOTE LEAD.
THE 33,000 REMAINING VOTES, THEY
ARE THROUGHOUT TO BE MOSTLY
REPUBLICANS.
IN CALIFORNIA 3, REPUBLICAN
KEVIN KYLIE HAS A SIX-POINT
LEAD.
AS OF TODAY.
THERE WERE A WHOPPING 150,000
VOTES TO COUNT.
CALIFORNIA 13 REMAINS TIGHT WITH
50,000 VOTES LEFT.
OVER IN CALIFORNIA 22, THE
REPUBLICAN HAS A FIVE-POINT LEAD
WITH AROUND 50,000 VOTES TO BE
COUNTED.
REPUBLICAN MIKE GARCIA HAS A
NINE-POINT LEAD IN CALIFORNIA
27.
KEVIN CAL BERT LEADS.
MICHELLE STEELE IS UP BY 8,
CALIFORNIA 45.
THAT'S WITH 80% REPORTING.
COLORADO, LAUREN BOEBERT IS
HOLDING ON TO A 1,000 VOTE LEAD.
NEW YORK 22, THE DEMOCRAT WOULD
NEED TO WIN 70% OF THE REMAINING
HANDFUL OF BALLOTS IN ORDER TO
CARRY HIS SEAT.
OTHER OUTLETS HAVE ALREADY
CALLED THIS RACE FOR REPUBLICAN
BRANDON WILLIAMS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE STATE OF
NEW YORK HAS BEEN A BRIGHT SPOT
FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AS
DAVE WASSERMAN REPORTED.
YOU CAN'T BLAME IT ALL ON BAD
REDISTRICTING.
THANKS IN PART TO AN INCREDIBLE
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE, LEE
ZELDIN, HE WOULD HAVE WON HIS
RACE IF IT WASN'T FOR WHAT I
CALL ACCELERATED MIGRATION.
THE NORTHERN LIBERAL STATES,
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA, MIDWESTERN STATES,
YOU HAVE WISCONSIN AND INDIANA
AND MICHIGAN AND ILLINOIS.
THEY ARE FLEEING THESE STATES IN
DROVES FOR WARMER WEATHER, LOWER
TAXES, A BETTER LIFESTYLE AND
LAST YEAR 52% OF MICHIGAN'S
MIGRATION WAS OUTBOUND.
IT WAS HIGHER IN NEW JERSEY.
53%.
58% IN NEW YORK.
IT WAS A MAJORITY IN
PENNSYLVANIA AS WELL.
FLORIDA, BY THE WAY, ADDING
500,000 NEW RESIDENTS IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS.
A 14% GROWTH IN THE LAST DECADE.
TENNESSEE GREW BY NEARLY 9%,
TEXAS OVER 15%.
THE CAROLINAS GREW BY AROUND
10%.
THESE POLITI